Speaker 1: The conspiracy theory that has been
widely debunked that being near someone vaccinated
against COVID 19 can do something to you has
not gone away. We have another one of these
very dangerous clips. This is, by the way, this is
Lauren Whiskey. Lauren, whiskey is not some random
person in the sense that she was the Delaware
Republican Party's candidate for the Senate in
2020. Thankfully, she lost. She is now claiming
she became sick after being around someone
who had their COVID vaccine and she
insists she's not crazy. Listen.
Speaker 2: Yeah, and the shedding is
extremely real. That's how I call it,
whatever it was. And you can't tell me it wasn't a
bioweapon because I've had flus before. I've had,
you know, tons of stuff wrong with me before. I'd
never experienced anything like it. It was like in
your head. It stole your joy. You couldn't, like,
had zero energy brain fog. Like, it was almost
like I was poisoned. It felt like, you know,
and, you know, you can't tell me COVID itself
wasn't a bioweapon, but I didn't catch COVID.
I campaigned up and down the state of Delaware.
Speaker 1: She probably had COVID.
Speaker 2: 2020 during COVID and didn't
catch anything. I shook a thousand hands, didn't
catch anything. I was around a family member who
just got boosted, didn't tell me I've never been
so sick in my life. And it wasn't like sickness.
It was like, I don't know how to explain it, but
whatever is shedding. Lots of them made me think
of him. Never quite been the same. I'm not as
sharp as I used to be. I go back and I watch some
interviews from 2019 20 to 2020 and I'm like, Wow,
I was completely different person. She's like,
I'm stupid. No, really, It did something to
me and you can't tell me it did it because I
know it did. And I'm not crazy, right?
Speaker 1: She's definitely not crazy,
guys. So listen, the most likely explanation is
the simplest, which is she got COVID. She was
around someone who had COVID and she got COVID.
The entire vaccine shedding thing, we've talked
about it before. The idea of shedding is someone
gets vaccinated and then they shed something off
of their body. It's not supported by scientific
evidence. It's not a real thing. The COVID
vaccines that are used in the U.S. don't contain
any live virus, so you can't shed virus. And the
concept of shedding vaccine just doesn't really
make any sense now if you're sick with COVID.
Then you are shedding the virus when you
cough and so on and so forth. And it seems
that that is probably what happened here. Now,
one interesting thing, she says she hasn't been
as sharp and whatever as many of you remember, I
got COVID in early December. I am experiencing a
long-covid symptom, which is my sense of smell is
diminished. Now, I never lost my sense of smell
or taste when I had COVID. It didn't go away,
but it was diminished. And what I realize now
is that it is still a diminished sense of smell.
And honestly, the way that I came to realize it is
since having COVID, I don't notice from just being
in a room with my baby daughter that she needs a
diaper change. I used to just perceive it from the
smell. People are understanding. I think what I'm
saying I don't notice anymore. And my girlfriend
will say, Does she need a diaper change? And I
was like, Oh, I don't know. Does she? Yeah, it
stinks in here. And I genuinely don't notice that
I can smell stuff, but it is diminished. And
I read it can be 12 to 18 months. Thankfully,
I'm not experiencing the brain fog that
Lauren Whiskey seems to be struggling with.